it's really lit and fun and crazy Kim
Kardashian is in vote literally on
Wednesday the Keeping Up with the
Kardashians star surprised fans by
securing her first solo cover for us
vote inside the mag Kim dropped some
major bombs I love that starting with
this
Kim is studying to become a lawyer the
38 year old revealed that she began a
four-year apprenticeship with a San
Francisco law firm and her goal is to
take the bar in 2022
she explained quote I just felt like I
wanted to be able to fight for people
who have paid their dues to society I
just felt like the system could be so
different and I wanted to fight to fix
it and if I knew more I could do more it
definitely opened up my eyes to a whole
different world Kim also opened up about
her husband Kanye West insisting that
despite having met with President Donald
Trump he doesn't belong to a political
party but he doesn't represent either
side but he doesn't want to be told what
he should be you might say things that
might get misinterpreted and Kim also
opened up about Kanye's bipolar disorder
explaining that everyone is in a quote
really good place I think everything and
life happens for a reason even if it's
really traumatic adding for him being on
medication is not really an option
because it just changes who he is
traveling a lot does set it off so he
doesn't travel as much as he used to but
honestly I never want to speak for him
because I am NOT in his mind
the most genuine person the reality star
also dishes on the surprising offer she
received from her man early on in their
relationship a fashion makeover quote he
took me to a Lakers game and a team of
stylists came to my house and when we
came home there were shoes piled up
almost to the ceiling that they had
taken out of my closet I only had two
pairs left and while you might expect
the Kardashian West's house to be
picture-perfect the writer paints a very
different picture boxes of Huggies
sitting inside the door a garage stacked
to the ceiling with adidas Yeezy boost
sneakers 15 oversized black suitcases
and at least 10 strollers and last but
not least Kim 100% knows what people
think of her it's so bizarre to me
she told the mag quote I love to be put
in a situation where I can have a
conversation with someone who might not
be inclined to think much of me because
I can guarantee they will have a
different opinion and understand what's
important to me after they've met me you
care less what anyone thinks or says
[Music]